all right Vicki and Jeremiah yes
Vicky and Jeremiah Jeremiah you've been
here before yes
um by yourself but uh you guys are a
couple
Vicky where are you from originally San
Francisco
what was your family like growing up
um I grew up with my mom mostly and it
was just pretty normal
except for when I got to high school and
started using drugs
and they got separated from my mother oh
really
where'd you go when you get separated I
decided to stay in uh random people's
houses getting high Slammy mess and like
just totally
doing a different route than I thought I
was gonna do what age was that did that
start
um 18 18. okay
well 21 when I started slamming meth
I started smoking heroin first and then
I tried the meth and like even using
drugs ever since yeah how old are you
now uh 32 32. Jeremiah how old are you
I'm 44. 44. you guys have been together
for how long yeah six months six months
we met in tiny homes and uh
her previous boyfriend went to jail and
if that just kind of happened and I mean
you got six months now we're living in
the park across the street just hustling
sparing chains selling drugs when we can
to make money Panhandle panhandling
mainly it's rough out there a lot of
crazy people running around
and a lot of violence what do you what
are your drugs currently uh I use
fentanyl I use about a gram to a gram
and a half a day a fentanyl they all get
sick I don't get high anymore I'm past
the point of getting high on fentanyl
yeah it's basically so used to it this
uh it makes me well so I don't throw up
or get real sick or anything like that
and Vicky what are you using I use
Fentanyl and mess too
and what do you guys do today and
sometimes Xanax yeah
what uh what are you guys doing to uh
make money uh I Panhandle and steal from
stores and take it downtown to sell for
money to defend more drugs and uh and do
that and I usually buy a Xanax to sell
to uh for can I get bottles cheap
downtown so I'm doing that and uh she's
out panhandling doing what she has to do
as a woman you know and yeah is that
does that mean like sex work sometimes
yeah
yeah and did you tell me you were
pregnant
yeah yeah
three years six weeks I don't really
even know how much how many months six
weeks ago six weeks is Jeremiah is the
father
yes
um that happens it's weird how we met
you know we met in tiny homes and
everything we just get along really well
I was hooking her up with with fentanyl
and uh her boyfriend went to jail and we
just kind of hooked up sneaking out each
other's rooms and doing drugs they
finally kicked us out but um we might
have a chance of getting housing soon uh
hopefully hopefully because stay in the
park it's freezing and freezing it's
dangerous I got stabbed one time uh a
year ago four times in the head in my
sleep some guy stabbed me I vaguely
remember wrestling with somebody but I
was on heroin so I don't remember it's
very dangerous on the street people
pulling guns on you and all kinds of
stuff since you came in last Jeremiah
that was what like maybe six months ago
yes right before you guys met yeah um
how is how has your life changed since
then I was hoping for the best but you
know I got out of hand at the tiny homes
getting high in my room setting the fire
alarms off like 30 times when I was
there then they knew me I was like I
always got away with it but they got a
new management and the management it
finally kicked me out and kicked her out
because they caught us uh sneaking into
those rooms in my room she caught it in
our room yeah we were getting high and
stuff yeah partying party yeah Vicky is
this like did you have
dreams of doing something else with your
life other than this this lifestyle
[Music]
belittle myself to get drugs or have to
like like beg every day it doesn't have
a job a car go to college and have like
my first boyfriend be my only boyfriend
so yeah a big difference yes kind of
went off the rails didn't it yeah and I
wasn't too happy about that I mean is
there anything in your childhood any
abuse anything like that that maybe set
you on this path uh that was my mom or
dad no nothing I didn't really see much
of my dad but I had my mom
it's really just the drugs that uh yeah
it's just like
like trying to get me not to do them
but um
it took my friends a lot to get me to
try things because I was like really
square like didn't want to do anything
bad but eventually I was just like I'm
like oh it went all out yeah I was like
forget it Dan do you have kids
apparently
um yeah I have one now where is your
your child he's um got adopted out and
he's in Arizona
hmm
so I mean are you looking forward to
having this child with a fentanyl
addiction or what do you
um how do you see it
kind of worried I don't think if I don't
have a place to live yeah we don't have
a place to live it's very likely you'll
lose the second child too yeah probably
probably
not unless I can like get off the
penthouse we're stuck on that planet
we're hooked yeah I don't think it lets
you put a gun in my head and stop me I
could stop her have you tried yeah I
couldn't I tried I tried medications I
tried I've been at 34 rehabs I've done
it all you know I mean luckily I had
interns under my parents knit and they
paid for rehab and then I went to I had
two and a half years clean at one point
I didn't like the lifestyle I moved
across the heroin or clean off of
fentanyl getting off Fentanyl and heroin
but I moved across from a sober living
yeah I got sober you got clean off a
fentanyl yes how'd you do that uh I went
to rehab and but I left after I got
clean I couldn't handle just being sober
the the pain the thinking the mind all
everything messages still
terrible months after you get clean I
went to rehab I took Suboxone for 10
days I detox I didn't get sick but the
the I just had this urge of like leaving
and the pain inside of me couldn't
handle being sober because I guess I'm
trying to block something in my life
maybe depression and being depressed or
something I'm not really a heroin or
opiate addict until about six years ago
I started doing heroin because of
depression and and I was hooked on crack
cocaine and all those other drugs and I
buy you know went all out I moved from a
sober living with two and a half years
clean across the street to a lot to get
high knowing I was going to lose
everything I lost my and I had an
apartment I lost that after a year just
doing drugs broke the windows went crazy
this is and then I started doing fennel
and I've been on it for five years
depending on one year heroin and in 24
years of crystal meth
so I have a long history and she's she
parties too hard really hard and so I
got to support her habit in my habit and
she does something she pitches in a lot
too we're a good couple together out
there and we're hoping to get housing
soon or something like that that way we
can at least be warm at night yeah warm
place to keep our stuff saved up and our
kid if we have one definitely that's the
most important part because we don't
know because of drugs and everything
that's how I left the first ones because
I was basically homeless but and also
like had all these drugs in my system
because I Didn't Know I Was Pregnant the
first time yeah so I was like what the
hell
but even still the pregnancy isn't
enough to get you clean from from the
drugs I can't like I've
I mean I would try I've tried I've gone
to rehab too it's really hard because my
body I get really depressed and it just
it hurts yeah the pain
I just don't see like I feel like I wish
they would not make it
a bad thing to smoke it because
when you're like do it for so long your
body just becomes dependent on it yeah
you're dependent you get sick if you
don't have it it's like we're not
getting really high you know what I mean
I don't get high at all anymore
yeah burn holes on our clothes all our
clothes yeah oh I do actually still but
quitting is just not really possible it
sounds like
it's not an option really right now
you're gonna we'll be around it either
way just selling it once pretty much
every day I gotta be uh you know support
my happier habit and when we don't have
it we have to pan a handle and do what
we gotta do to get our drugs what's your
biggest fear at this point well this
year is getting arrested
and going to a jail or prison or
something yeah but but the way you think
all these ears the way the way things
are going it looks like you'll be on
fentanyl for the rest of your life
I don't think my body can handle it
anymore like the rest of my life because
it they don't really know what it does
do but I've got really sick where
I've ingested things out of my body that
is from like residue of some drugs or
fentanyl from the stomach it's like a
bile or something like that I got really
sick twice and I think that's the way
fennel leaves your body is through
through your like it comes out of your
lungs and comes out
I got really deathly ill almost died I
go to urgent care and
the apartment for IB and all that what
do you guys go through emotionally with
this lifestyle
up and down
it's pretty good we kind of fight
sometimes over drugs and things like
that but is it difficult being a couple
it's interesting on the streets it's
interesting I never had it I always been
about myself on the street it's the
first time I actually had a relationship
on the street but I think he's
dating somebody to get some money
doesn't bother me does it bother you
yeah
well it bothers me a little bit it took
me a long time until like
I don't know
it just doesn't seem really worth it you
know because then I was like worried you
know but if they give me something
trying to kill me or like you know
it's not yeah it's just
it's a crazy lifestyle for a couple but
most definitely
if anything could happen to me I could
be selling drugs in the wrong
neighborhood and get shot or anything
could happen what's the craziest thing
you guys have been through in your six
months
gain getting robbed at gunpoint a couple
times the very vicious uh robbery
there's a lot of fighting
then you're staying up in North
Hollywood yes in North Hollywood there's
there's gangs up there yeah there's gang
territories and all that and they Patrol
the park a lot so it's hard
to like be we go to different spots in
the park every night we don't stay in
one place
Vicky what's what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear is I'm gonna end up
going to jail like he said because
it's so depressing in there I hate it um
not only that is like maybe losing touch
with reality a little bit or getting
lost you know and just like kind of just
ending up in a miserable cycle and not
being able to free myself from like
things in my head that like sometimes I
create
and not to be able to like just like you
know take care of myself I don't want to
be like
you know like on the streets forever you
know yeah I want to grow and live I want
to get the house have a car have a life
yeah I never had because every high
school I went to they're all have houses
kids normal lives and I guess they drink
once in a while you know what I mean
yeah but they can handle it given your
fentanyl addiction is it even there's no
way my final addiction is so bad right
now or something funny getting a job and
getting a house if I could shoot it I'm
scared of shooting it because I want to
get high you know what I mean but I
haven't shot it yet but I've done hot
rails and other ways of doing it
sniffing lines of it
um
so the next option is probably shooting
it if I want to feel something isn't
like getting a job getting a house kind
of a
um actually I worked hard times
sometimes for people and help them out
so cleaning
that's once in a while but I I'm not
getting a job at Ralph's I had a job at
Ralph's at one point they said when I
get off the drugs call them they rehire
me so we're working at a grocery store
isn't really going to get you a house no
not really it's Union though that's the
benefit insurance and everything
stupid
and I do crystal too I smoke
a couple grams of Crystal a day prior
why do you do the crystal
I like the energy I like crossfading the
two drugs
it's like rushing all that kind of
so
is that the same reason you do it Vicky
yeah I do it because
um it keeps me going like up and
and the the
um the smoking you know is like what I
love the taking that hit the taste yeah
it's just it helps me relax and just I'm
just so used to it you'll stay up how
many days on that a lot I do not sleep
like at all like three important for
like four days in a row five days in a
row sometimes I'd really ever sleep she
does all the time driving me nuts
like I cannot sleep but one of the stats
to stay up pretty much to keep eye out
when we're in certain spots and
locations in North Hollywood and how did
you get pregnant were you using any kind
of contraception or no we were using
protection so
given your lifestyle you thought
pregnancy was kind of okay didn't think
about it didn't think about it
is a spur of the moment how we met
well that thing
looking back at your lives is there
anything that you would have I would
love to provide a home for her like it
works out we still stay together for a
while but at a home or apartment and get
a part-time job and give her the what
she what she wants to deal with her a
career art or dance you think there's a
good possibility of doing something like
that 50 50 maybe if I'm lucky
hmm
and what would you wait for housing
maybe right now so if I get that I'm
gonna get a part-time job and start
working and but I'll still have to use
that work all the smoke in the bathroom
and try to keep my drug habit from me
getting sick and that would be a whole
other episode of things
so
then you'll miss work if you don't have
it like you can't go to work yeah
you can't barely walk or move
right no it seems fennel is it only
costs 30 cents to make and China wanted
to import it here to kill all the
Americans that's the room around the
street and all these drug cartels got
the recipe and they're making it and
it's everywhere
so you know it's going down cheaper in
price it was a hundred degrees and
they're also putting in other drugs now
I think yeah they're mixing it with like
God knows what chemicals that's what I'm
saying getting sick and stuff
so fennel's a daily drug
one hit I take could kill 10 people
at least get your body so conditioned
yeah those conditions so used to it just
said we have a steady habit every day so
Vicky how much are you doing today uh as
much as I can get like a gram at least
because it's hard for me to buy as much
as I would like
but
it doesn't even do anything it's slowing
down because you're pregnant it's not
she slowed down a little bit but yeah I
get on or about that I want her to stop
but it's just she's I got her own things
going on her mind and stuff so hopefully
we can get through this and and have a
kid if not
um I don't know what to say it's gonna
be sad say a sad story yeah
is there anything you guys have learned
from
your your experience is doing this and
and going through this pregnancy and all
that
I know it's the first time I got someone
pregnant in my life
this is probably not the ideal way to do
it no it's not yeah
but I'll be there if I have to
so
Vicky what would you say is maybe the
most important lesson you've learned
from living this lifestyle
um
that it's better to
day like around people you know and not
trust people what by what they say
because for some reason I always fall
into what people tell me and it's a
complete opposite lie like they're just
saying it and I just like I should know
already you know that they're just lying
to me so definitely to just stick to
myself and not be so open you know
how far along are you in your pregnancy
about
six to seven weeks six seven weeks yeah
and abortion is not uh I think it's past
that we tried we talked to somebody
about it we're looking into it abortion
it's like too sad you know yeah it's
just I couldn't do that that's one thing
I could do that like conscious I can't
do that my conscience
all right Vicki and Jeremiah thank you
so much for sharing your story I wish
you guys
all the luck in the world I think you'll
need it thank you all right you guys
thank you